好 那我們現在來看一下作業一要怎麼做
如果還沒有完成作業一的同學可以看一下
那他說利用Google Antigraph IDE製作網頁檔案
然後再把這個檔案部署到GitHub Page上面
那我現在示範一個不是Google Antigraph IDE的方法
也可以做網頁
那因為這個要安裝會花一些時間
所以我們先直接用Gemini
然後再來
它的目的是要製作地球物理課程介紹網頁
所以我必須要有一些素材
那這個素材可以是
從這個課程資訊上面下來的
那我們就把這個課程資訊把它複製
然後就回到這個Gemini
然後貼上
然後跟他說我要製作一個課程
介紹的網頁
然後要什麼風格
然後未來要
部署在GitHub的Page上面
請大家給我一個
index.html的檔案
我等一下會把我講的這句話
貼給大家
然後下面就把剛複製的內容
貼上去
那如果你要
斷行的話
不要直接按Enter
要把Shift按住再按Enter
它就會
切到下一行
然後再按Ctrl V
然後按Enter
那另外一方
另外一邊呢
就是你的GitHub的賬號要先登入
然後我們就可以
那邊有一些操作要進行
可以做成一個網頁
我們可以現在先同步
把GitHub開啟
好
假定大家都已經知道
都有GitHub的賬號
然後你
然後進到GitHub之後呢
因為我已經打過密碼
所以剛剛不需要再打
右上角這裡有個加號
旁邊的箭頭
我們點這個new repository
然後就給它一個repository name
這個名字隨意給
但我建議不要有
最好不要用中文
用英文比較好
然後最好不要有空格
用底線或是dash來隔開
然後最好是有意義的英文字
這樣這幾個重點
然後因為我太多什麼
Geophysics Intro
我這樣會搞混
所以我給它一個Test
不然我會太多一樣的名字
然後底下這裡有個Add Read Me
我覺得可以開啟
當然你如果不開啟也可以
也沒關係
所以就給Title
然後這個開啟
就可以按綠色按鈕
它就會幫你建立一個
一個倉庫或者說一個專案
在你的GitHub賬號裡面
那這個專案或這個倉庫呢
其實是非常有用的東西
因為你可以把你的一些程式碼
或者一些檔案
或者一些材料
或者圖片
PDF檔
一些課程的相關內容
通通都放到上面
然後這個Repository未來可以讓你的其他的AI Agent的工具去讀它
比如說老師現在有用這個有個叫做Cursor
這是一個AI Agent的工具
那這個Cursor的工具上面可以指定到你的GitHub的專案裡面
所以我就可以在這邊直接跟他對話
然後就可以做出這個課程的網頁
同學可以看一下老師這個製作的過程
就是給他一些教材
我先把一些材料放到GitHub上面
然後就跟他說我要做網頁
那他就會幫我做好
這個就是用GitHub當做一個媒介
然後他因為他在雲端
所以你可以用地端
就是你的本機的一些工具跟他連線
你也可以用雲端的其他工具跟他連線
那它就是一個儲存你的材料的一個地方
我畫一個圖給大家看一下
我覺得這個概念非常的實用
而且重要
所以同學看一下
老師花一點時間來講一下這個東西
好
然後我畫一個圖
這個中間這個圈圈呢
就是就是GitHub
GitHub
那GitHub是一個在雲端
就是在網路上的一個空間
然後這個空間是免費的
你可以放很多東西上去
所以你可以自己上傳一些資料或檔案丟上去
這個假設這是me
我可以丟東西上去
可以丟什麼東西呢
可以丟PDF
我可以丟JPG檔
當然我也可以丟文字檔
那我也可以丟程式碼
或是Python的程式碼.
py的檔案或者
是什麼反
正任何檔案都可以丟那
它好像也是有一個空間上限好像
是500MB之類的但是
一般來說都很夠用而且
你在裡面你可以
設定很多個專案所以
GitHub這個賬戶裡面你可以
有一個專案兩
個專案三
個專案
然後這每一個專案呢
你都可以丟這些特定的檔案
把它放上去
把它放上去專案
然後某個檔案放到這個專案
好 這樣就是你跟他的關係
就是丟檔案
然後在你的電腦這一端呢
你可能會有一些程式
你這個程式可能是
我們教過的那個
Entergravity
在你的電腦端
你可以直接用Enter Gravity
在你的筆電裡面或桌機裡面
直接access這裡的資料
你可以丟上去也可以拉下來
然後你可以把你做好的
你本機的程式跑完的結果
或者是程式碼
把它儲存在這個這一端
所以這一端是在雲端
然後這個時候比較有彈性的地方在這裡
你可能會有
CheckGPT的賬號
如果你有訂閱制的CheckGPT
好像現在不用訂閱制也可以
假設你有CheckGPT
然後網頁版的
那你就可以用這個CheckGPT
跟你的GitHub連線
連線的意思是說
你可以直接在CheckGPT這邊
跟他說我要
把這裡面的內容做整理
然後寫成網頁
然後存起來
你在這邊講
然後他就會幫你做好
然後放進去
儲存在這個某一個專案裡面
那你的TradeGPT必須跟某一個專案連線
假設是跟這個專案連線
那你就可以操縱這個專案裡面的檔案
然後跟他互動
那不只TradeGPT
像我現在用的另外一個叫Cursor
Cursor的網頁本
它也可以跟他聯動
然後我覺得更有彈性的是
但是因為我們
平常出門在外不會隨時隨地把筆電拿出來
就開啟來做事
但是我們很可能把手機拿出來
然後做一些事情
你知道我們等公車或者是坐捷運
或者是在坐火車這種或坐高鐵
我們只要有一臺手機
我就可以開始寫作業
然後做研究
怎麼做到的呢
因為我的手機裡面
假設這是我的手機
這是我
然後我的手機裡面呢
有Chad GPT有Cursor
所以我就可以用手機連到這裡
連到這邊
然後我直接在我的手機裡面說
我現在有這個檔案
然後你幫我做成網頁
做好之後呢
它就會把它
這個GitHub裡面的這個內容
做成網頁
然後放進去
或者你跟Cursor說
說幫我收集跟Play Tectonic Theory相關的資料
收集完之後幫我放進去
然後收集完他就會幫你擺在這裡面
然後你同時又有
你叫Cursor去找資料
然後叫CheerGPT去做網頁
他找完之後你就跟CheerGPT說
幫我把這個專案裡面內容做成網頁
或者是寫成一個PDF檔
或者做成一個PPT都可以
然後他就會把你的結果放在這裡
所以你可能今天早上要來上學
然後剛好有一個作業是要PPT
要上臺報告某一堂課
然後你的車程假設有一個小時都在坐車
然後很幸運的你有座位
沒有座位也可以站著按
然後你一上車就跟他說
幫我Cursor收集Platectonic的資料
然後CheerGD幫我整理資料
然後做成網頁
然後放進去
然後等到你下車的時候
你的PPT已經在這邊等你了
然後你的網頁已經做好了
然後你走進教室就把這個網址直接開啟
直接講或PPT下載
你就可以報告了
這個是完全是有可能的事情
但這個最重要的關鍵就在於
我覺得很重要的就是這個GitHub
它這個媒介非常的強大
讓你變成你不用手邊有電腦
你的電腦在雲端
你的程式在雲端
你的agent也在雲端
那你就透過你的手機
就可以開始工作
你只要講一句話
它就開始做事
那如果你不想用打的
你還可以語音輸入
就是按一下語音輸入
然後按send
然後它就開始
照你的規劃去進行
所以這個GitHub
它除了
它也可以用於分享
分享你的資料跟內容給其他的人
那也可以跟別人共編
假設有另外一個人也是跟你這個專案相關的
你們兩個可以共同編輯同一個專案
然後可以share彼此的資料
好 那我們 我剛剛那個題外話講完了
我再切回來這裡
所以這個GitHub第一個申請帳號
申請完之後至少我們要會開專案
開專案好開完了就變成這樣
然後我們可以把檔案丟上來
也可以拉下來
那我先示範一下
如果你要丟檔案的話
就這個add file
然後upload files
那你就看你的本機電腦裡面有什麼檔案
你就可以丟上去
假設隨便丟一個文字檔
然後Commit Change
然後你就可以看到
哎 檔案進來了
然後你點它還可以看到檔案的內容
那如果你要下載這個檔案的話
你可以按這個
然後還可以下載
然後任何一個專案
只要它是Public
你都可以把它複製到你的倉庫來
你的賬號下面
所以同學們也可以複製這個賬號
到你的Github裡面
這個我們等一下再講
我們現在先把那個作業儀寫完
然後我再回來這裡
它好像已經做好了
那我就下載
下載好
下載完之後呢
你會看到它這個檔名並不是index.html
它是code artifacts
所以我先把它改一下名字
因為我們要放在Github上面
上面他的名字一定要叫做index
然後副檔名是html
所以是不用改
所以這個內容check一下
他是index
然後點html
所以檔案的名稱是正確的
那我們就再回來這個github這裡
那我們可以回到他的手
他的主要的畫面就點這個code
就可以回到這個畫面
然後我們現在把剛剛做好的網頁檔案上傳
Add File Upload Files
然後你可以用拉的也可以用點的
我現在用拉的給同學看
這個是檔案總管
把它拖曳到這裡放開
然後讓它有一段時間上傳
完成之後就點綠色按鈕
它就開始處理你的檔案
然後把它上傳到你的GitHub
這邊就可以看到你的程式碼
已經被放上來了在這裡
好
這樣子已經快要成功80%了
我們現在有這個檔案
把它變成網頁的下一步呢
就是這邊要仔細看
我們要點這個settings
然後左邊這裡有個pages
然後再點這個branch
這邊有個none改成main
好
然後這邊都不用動
直接點save
這個意思是說
說它E-Hub它有很多分支
那我們現在是在主分支底下
然後這個index.hdml的檔案呢
會在主分支底下的根目錄底下
然後我們把這個設定存起來
那我們來看一下
因為這個已經是主分支
主分支的根目錄就是最外面這一層
所以主分支的根目錄底下
要有一個這個檔
然後我剛剛save了
所以它就會開始工作
可以點這個Actions
可以點這個他的Workflow
看到他正在做Build Deploy
他現在還在工作
所以一直轉
等他工作完了
他就會產生一個網址給你
這個網址就是我們做好的網頁
相當陽春的網頁
所以同學看這樣就做完作業一了
他有分幾個分頁
就很快的就完成了
其實非常的簡單
那如果你要
但你要增加一些內容呢
也非常容易
但是要有素材
所以你可以繼續再跟他講話
給他一些素材
然後叫他更新檔案
那他就會幫你產生新的檔案
那我們再把它推上去GitHub
那你的網頁就會越來越豐富
就可以像同學這樣
做了這麼豐富的內容
好 那這個就是作業一的部分
我們先講到這兒
停止錄影